okay I won't lie I did actually think
about doing this review in a wedding
dress so we move along with overdue
Doctor Who and we now get to bridge
series two and seriously which means
special time which means the runaway
bride and this one I was actually kind
of looking forward to I mean I've said
more than a few times at this point in
case people didn't know Donna's my
favorite companion Donna is the best I
loved on it and this is of course her
introduction now I haven't rewatched
this in a long time and I remember not
really caring for it very much but I
hoped that you know doing what I have
been doing for most of these reviews and
sort of focusing when watching something
that I remember not liking focusing and
trying to find the good in it and also a
couple of the fact that like it's Donna
that I thought you know what I think
this will be kind of an enlightening
experience you know to watch and
appreciate it in a way I did before that
didn't happen oh boy okay where do we
start
okay how about this your standard Doctor
Who episode is about 45 minutes this
runs about an hour I'm pretty sure those
entire 15 extra minutes are comprised of
characters shouting short sentences at
each other there is a lot of incredibly
repetitive shouting in this thing like
nothing gets shouted that doesn't get
shouted at least two more times in the
span of the next five seconds after gets
shouted the first time Donna shouts the
doctor shouts the racnoss empress shouts
everybody just keeps
shouting and it's so infuriating because
the few moments where Donna is allowed
to do something other than shout I see
the hints of that character who I adore
and love and wish could have been on the
show forever but when she's shouting
it's like the shouting just drowns out
her character she loses all personality
I'm sure they thought that the shouting
like made her more of a spitfire no it
just made her really irritating and I
know that's also like part of the things
she's getting on the doctors nerves and
and you know Lance didn't even really
like her and all that stuff but it's
it's the classic thing that I have I
keep pointing out in movie after movies
show after show when you make a
character deliberately irritating to the
character that we already like in this
case the doctor there's a really good
chance that you're also gonna make them
irritating to the audience as well and
in this one as much as I love Donna
she's kind of insufferable for most of
this it's her quieter moments that work
so like after shouting at the doctor for
her first one two three minutes on
screen she then you know runs to the
TARDIS door opens it up and goes quiet
and the look on her face and this moment
of her saying you know it's this is
letting the cold in or whatever her
exact or is it that is characterization
that is that is Donna the shouting is
just shouting but unfortunately there's
a lot a lot a lot of shouting but the
shouting is not the only problem with
this this really this is not a story
that needed an hour to be told which
honestly is true of the majority of the
holiday specials not all of them but I
think a pretty decent chunk
they are telling fairly straightforward
stories that do not need the amount of
time that they're given and I think this
one honestly might be the most egregious
example of that because this is actually
a really straightforward story doctor
you know
right ends up on the TARDIS doctor tries
to return her she's being tracked down
oh there's a big monster oh it's dead
this is a pretty basic you know few
points along the thing process but like
I said they bulk it out with screaming
so that this isn't a story that feels
like it demanded extra time in order to
be told and the other thing that is
working against this is that this is
this is Doctor Who being deliberately
campy and I do make a distinction
between campy and silly um and I've done
another video you know talking about my
thoughts on when doctor who gets a
little bit too silly for its own good
but when it gets to the level of camp
which some of this is particularly with
the racnoss and I'll come back to her I
don't like Doctor Who to be campy and
for a couple reasons I'm not partial to
camp at the best of times and it really
doesn't work for me when camp is
injected into something that I like but
I I like that isn't always a campy and
like Doctor Who can't embrace a certain
amount of ridiculousness but seeing this
episode it brings me back to like that
that very first episode where a plastic
bin a Mickey it has that vibe to it at
times and I just I just don't like it I
don't like when doctor who gets this
spurious this fluff I I don't need every
story to be heavy and dramatic or
whatever but when it's this light when
it's this light and knows that it's this
light and plays it up like it's a
cartoon like I hate the music in this
and actually honestly as much as I love
Donna I don't like a lot of the music
that's done to underscore her moments
with possibly the exception of left-turn
most of the music used to underscore is
very it's very cartoonish dee dee dee
dee dee dee it's this bouncy and like it
it feels like something out of a Looney
Tunes it I don't like it and this whole
episode has that vibe to it has that
feel to it everything is
not just for sci-fi or horrific reason
purposes or dramatic purposes it's
exaggerated for the cut for comedic
purposes and you know it's also not
funny so that doesn't help III like I
don't know what there is to say about
the story aside from the fact that its
simplicity to the point that it didn't
need an hour oh well I said I'd come
back to the racnoss so let's talk about
that particular brand of pain so mm-hmm
my memory of her was that the look was
really impressive and the performance
didn't quite work and that was a severe
understatement the performance is an
absolute mess it first of all there's
the fact that her speech is severely
impeded by the stuff that they've got
shoved into our mouths so you you look
at some vampire related stuff from like
mid-90s in previous to that and it's
fairly common for actors to get a little
bit of a of a odd sound from the extra
stuff she's got that in spades the bride
has arrived my children yeah it's it's
really bad and and the performance she
delivered like I had forgotten that
between lines she like laughs but it's
not a laugh it's it's like that that
that reminds me something got a red
dwarf which is in fact an outright
comedy like that that's like Crichton
trying to learn how to laugh and I'm
surprised it didn't stick in my head as
much considering how much the wire
yelling hungry Shae over and over again
really irritated the ever-loving heck
out of me in idiots Lantern and that
suck in my head I'm surprised that it
didn't sink in my head how many times
she bellows I lost count seriously I
just I part of me thought I should back
up and be counting how many of these
they there are but that was overridden
by the part of me that absolutely did
not want to hear this character
screaming that any more it's so bad as
this long drawn-out scene and like they
didn't know how to bring emphasis to
what was going on other than to have her
shout that over and over again at the
same volume no matter what the shot is
it's not like they fade it down so it's
more of a background feature it's at the
same volume every time she shouts it and
then the episode has the one part of it
that really has much relevance for the
doctor as a character which is him
really enacting overall potentially
arguably overly harsh vengeance you know
it it's a debatable whether or not it
was necessary but he seems to be taking
a sort of superior satisfaction in in
what he has decided to do and his
standing there and Donna telling him
doctor you can stop now is actually
important but it's a moment that in this
episode itself actually doesn't even
work
it works in hindsight retro actively
because of left turn but here in and of
itself it does not work because the
episode has not been of a mood or a tone
that justifies this sudden shift into
him committing genocide and having this
really dark moment it's completely
unearned within this story and it's
probably why they had her shouting my
ginger and over and over again
to emphasize the fact that he's wiping
out he's wiping out newborns effectively
and dr. who can at its best juggle
contrasting tones heck the previous
two-parter did it way better than this
because yo army of ghosts and doomsday
is fun as a Jew bar is a lot of fun and
ridiculous fun the Cybermen argue with
the Daleks and make you pointing out
it's like Stephen Hawking having a fight
with a speedy clock that's silly and fun
but it was able to have that transition
into the sadness of the end still work
partially because we understood the
threat was real the threat never felt
unthreatening because I can't think
about our word all of a sudden and so
that was part of why that worked and it
also didn't turn on a dime the way that
did there there was a build-up to
hinting at the Rosa's fear of not being
with doctor and then yeowch then she
comes back and so it it's sort of it
built that fear it built the okay well
here's our solution wait but what if
this happens wait Rose you need to go no
wait she came back no what's gonna
happen
like it built it didn't suddenly go ah
silly silly silly can't be weird spider
or funny performance dark that doesn't
work it doesn't work and I didn't work
this like I think the only moments that
work legitimately work are the quiet
moments between Donna and the doctor so
like I said when Donna first looking out
the door of the TARDIS when they sort of
take a minute when they realize after
all the shouting and after they get away
from the pile of fish which girl why the
heck are they back oh so we can but
Santa's in and we can have Christmas
imagery great it has nothing to do with
anything it was stupid the last time at
least it was semi justified before now
it's just dumb for the sake of dumb but
anyway after that whole chase happens
she again has a quiet conversation with
the doctor and that moment I like the
last sort of bit she has with him where
he offers her a chance to come on the
TARDIS and she says no you know you
scare me to death
and the sincerity of her voice when she
says that and her invite in her advise
him say doctor just promise me you won't
travel alone because you need someone to
stop you those moments those scenes
those quiet moments between the doctor
and Donna are genuinely good but they're
really kind of it I'm not sure how much
I remembered those scenes before going
back and revisiting this but I can tell
you that I had forgotten how bad how
painful the vast majority of this thing
is I really yeah III don't I don't want
to watch it again like ever like I I
remember how how the doctor and Donna
met I will happily just skip to series 4
if I want if I need a Donna fix cuz this
nope so that's the runaway bride not
nothing exactly what I wanted to kick
things off for this sort of next leg of
things but it is what it is what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about a whole bunch of
stuff to do buttons links
subscribe and things and stuff and you
know what there is to do link to the
patreon be appreciated and that will
wrap it up for this one folks so check
out the stuff down in the description
but you know what if you don't want to
that's also ok because at the end of the
day you folks are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is German
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]